hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast of
in situ
immune profiling of heart transplant
biopsies improves diagnostic accuracy
and rejection risk stratification
presented by
dr elliott pacer a physician with the
advanced heart failure and transplant
medicine program
at the university of pennsylvania my
name is bethany bemnick
global application scientist at aqua
biosciences and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by us here at akoya
biosciences
to learn more about akoya and how our
finoptix platform
which will be showcased in today's
webinar can support your multiplexing
needs
please visit our website at
www.akoyabio.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click the send button also please
note
that you can share this webinar on your
personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
following dr pacer's presentation we
will have a live q a session
where we will answer as many questions
as time allows
this webinar will be recorded so you and
your colleagues will be able to view it
on demand
following its conclusion if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
it now gives me great pleasure to
introduce our presenter dr elliott pacer
dr pacer completed his medical training
at drexel university college of medicine
and went on to complete his residency in
cardiovascular fellowship
at the hospital of the university of
pennsylvania with scientific training in
translational research
and clinical training in advanced heart
failure and transplant medicine
the goal of dr pacer's research aims to
integrate automated morphologic
analysis pipelines with molecular
genomic
and transcriptomic data to improve
prediction and biological
characterization of important patient
outcomes
for a complete biography of dr pacer
please visit
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen and now dr pacer
you may begin your presentation
thank you all for attending this webinar
today i'm going to be talking about
heart transplant medicine and how
quantitative histopathology and in situ
immune profiling are helping to
modernize the field and improve patient
care
by way of overview i'll begin with some
background on heart transplantation and
allograft projection
as well as a brief conceptual
introduction to computational histologic
analysis
and some of our early results using
these methods in heart transplant
i'll then present the results of recent
work utilizing quantitative multiflex
immunofluorescence or qmif
and how this computationally empowered
approach may help address key unmet
needs within post-transplant care
i know we have a diverse audience here
so in order to provide some context i'll
quickly review some background
on heart transplantation allograft
rejection and the limitations of
conventional histologic rejection
diagnosis
heart transplantation is the treatment
of choice for end-stage cardiomyopathy
and while outcomes are generally quite
good
vigilance is required to minimize uh
morbidity and mortality after
transplantation
in particular a primary focus of
post-transplant care is the
surveillance for and prevention of
cardiac allograft rejection
why is this a primary focus because
rejection is common and because it can
be deadly
rejection occurs in 30 to 40 percent of
patients in the first year
in terms of patient outcomes acute
rejection along with infections caused
by immunosuppression medicines we used
to prevent rejection
represent the leading causes of early
post-transplant death
and in the later post-transplant period
a couple of years after transplant the
leading causes of death are sequelae of
chronic rejection
along with malignancies which really are
also a consequence of the
immunosuppression medicines we use
in other words post-transplant care is
really all about immunosuppression
trying to use
just enough to prevent rejection without
going overboard and needlessly
increasing the risk of
infections and cancers
because of the frequency and morbidity
of cardiac allograft projections
intensive surveillance with
endomyocardial biopsy has been endorsed
by transplant
guidelines for decades as part of this
surveillance heart transplant recipients
typically undergo 12 or more scheduled
biopsies in their first year
post-transplant alone
these biopsy procedures are endovascular
they're basically just a long catheter
inserting the neck or in the leg
and a biopsy is passed to the heart
where four sort of one millimeter by one
millimeter pieces of tissue are grabbed
from the inner ventricular septum
pretty routine but also invasive
since 1990 the international society for
heart and lung transplantation has
issued formal guidelines for the
histologic assessment of projection on
biopsies which we obtain
um the isagelt endorses
qualitative histologic grading of h e
stained slides
for uh basically assessing for the
presence of inflammatory cell
infiltrates which are these little blue
cells you can see there
as well as rough estimates of infiltrate
extent number and signs of vaguely
defined myocyte damage or encroachment
you can see the grading criteria pretty
much pulled from the guidelines
themselves on the right of the screen in
the table there it's a four grade scale
zero out of three are
and brief descriptions of what to find
each one
you can put yourself in the position of
someone trying to actually apply these
criteria
you can probably appreciate that the
vagaries and subjectivities of these
descriptions uh
are a bit of a challenge
um sort of taking you into a few
examples of grading in action if you
will here are three examples of
different ish lt grades on the left we
have a 1r miles projection case in the
middle of two of our
moderate rejection and on the right a 3r
severe rejection
there are probably real albeit subtle
differences in the number of density of
little blue cells
between these slides and maybe even some
difference in the degree of
so-called encroachment on the myocytes
but given the vagaries of the criteria
exactly where to draw the line of
distinction between one great another is
obviously going to end up being fairly
subjective as a result it's really not
surprising that when we take a look at
the real world performance of
conventional ishlt grading we see that
the fields diagnostic standard is far
from a
gold standard in practice
ishlt grading is neither reliable nor
particularly accurate
the poor reliability in terms of
integrator agreement has been
investigated for
decades and really has been consistently
found to be lacking
overall pairwise agreement in the 60s is
pretty common
dismal agreement on the high grades of
rejection which are the ones that tend
to result in major treatment changes
and again this has been found on every
study for decades including studies by
my own research team
um the
when it comes to accuracy uh the grading
criteria really fair little better
um if we define accuracy the ability of
a test to identify the entity of actual
clinical interest
uh conventional grading is quite lacking
ishlt grades
correlate poorly with the actual
clinical severity of an ongoing
rejection event
this means that there's real discordance
between histology and the patient's
clinical presentation and
uh it comes in really two flavors um
poor positive predictive value is
highlighted by case series data which
shows that many asymptomatic patients
with high grade histology can experience
benign clinical courses and resolution
of that histology even if they don't
receive any actual rejection treatment
and then poor negative predictive value
which is highlighted by
case series evidence showing that up to
half of people who actually have a
serious
evident allograft injury with change in
with heart failure symptoms and changing
their echocardiogram
about half of them have sort of
low-grade histology so
overall accuracy is obviously limited
here
um finally as if poor reliability and
accuracy weren't enough
um ishlt grading also lacks the ability
to stratify patients by future rejection
risk
this represents a major barrier to
personalized post-transplant management
um as you can probably imagine
um these shortcomings of the current
standard have significant effects on the
practice of transplant medicine
poor iterator agreement creates
confusion and hinders multi-center
research
poor accuracy causes direct patient harm
in many cases with false positives if
you will
causing false alarm and over treatment
with dangerous immunosuppression while
false negatives
would result in false reassurance and
potentially delayed treatment of a
potentially serious rejection syndrome
and then finally the inability to
provide risk stratification causes a
more indirect level of harm
with low-risk patients exposed to
excessive biopsy procedures
and excessive immunosuppression which
for what they need to manage their risk
of rejection
while high-risk patients are exposed to
potentially insufficient
surveillance biopsies and potentially
dangerous premature weaning of
immunosuppression
i think it's finally also worth noting
actually that uh
the lack of a reliable and accurate gold
standard for rejection has really held
the field back more generally
in terms of development and validation
of newer technologies for rejection
surveillance
it's been awfully hard for people to
validate imaging and serologic tests
when the the standard of which they're
comparing themselves is
terrible um you don't know how to
interpret your results and it
really becomes a muddled mess which is
why in large part
reject biopsy remains sort of the
standard
so to summarize this little background
section rejection surveillance is a
major
part of post-transplant care current
diagnostic standard and limited
reliability
accuracy and prognostic value which
affects both innovation and
patient outcomes and despite decades of
research no method has replaced
morphologic analysis
as the diagnostic standard it should be
pretty clear then that there's an unmet
need for tools capable of improving the
diagnostic value of the biopsy tissues
we get so frequently
so in the interest of being problem
solvers and not just problem identifiers
my research team has chosen to utilize
some
modern computational approaches in an
attempt to bring objectivity and
quantitation to
traditionally subjective and qualitative
discipline of histopathology
um
histology is a very old field as you all
probably know and
even something as seemingly modern as
allograft projection actually has
morphologic characteristics that have
been recognized for more than a century
this is not to say that histology is
outdated it's just that uh
rather that the information contained
within astrology samples is
such obvious and evident importance that
it was even apparent to people a hundred
years
ago using sort of the most primitive
tools of modern medicine
um this is pretty unsurprising histology
is fundamentally the end product of
molecular biology and a precursor of
physiology
as such should be expected to contain
some pretty valuable information within
it
the issue facing the transplant field
has been how to maximize and standardize
the extraction of this valuable
information
clearly simplified qualitative h e based
grading criteria have not been very
satisfying
while the human mind is a powerful piece
of pattern recognition hardware
and while our pathologist if any of you
have worked with them or are them
clearly see a great deal when they look
at histology slides
they don't always see the same things or
describe them the same way or
ascribe to them the same degree of
importance
so while einstein probably said it
better the real problem is that
conventional grading is the result of an
oversimplification of expert knowledge
and it's this over simplification that
really comes at the expense of
resolution
in the case of allograft rejection i
would argue and i think many would that
the cost is simply too high
and it's in recognition of this tension
between sophistication and
standardization that our group turned to
computational image analysis
an emerging technology that might just
let us standardize and disseminate
complex histologic
information without losing some of those
nuances and details that make it so
valuable
histopathology as we've already sort of
covered is traditionally dominated by
direct manual human analysis
but this really need not be the case in
the 21st century
over the past decade uh whole slide
scanner technology has become pretty
commonplace
at almost every major hospital and many
research labs
enabling digital archiving of histology
samples
while this was originally intended to
facilitate a variety of telepathology
workflows
the value of this goes way beyond
telemedicine
fundamentally these digital slides are
not just pictures they're
pieces of data a digital image is a
matrix of numbers
with position in the matrix
corresponding to a pixel position in
space
and the numerical values corresponding
to pixel color and intensity
so if we can just deconvolute an image
or picture back into these discrete
quantified constituents it becomes
possible to perform a rigorous analysis
of the data within it
this is really the domain of computer
vision technology
and it's something that we're going to
focus on for at least in part for the
rest of this talk
basically and fundamentally the purpose
is to try and turn
this histology image into this a bunch
of data
um and these days it's possible to do
this
um the advantages of such methods are
pretty clear i think uh first of all it
can obviously bring objectivity and
quantitation
it adds rigor it adds reliability and
can certainly have predictive power
it also comes with several additional
benefits which are somewhat inherent to
software
approaches to diagnostics these include
easy dissemination remote access
potential high throughput potential
the ability to self-improve as you feed
it more data
as well as the discovery of new biology
when sort of unexpected predictive
features pop out of models
and i think finally of particular
relevance to this talk the potential to
enhance predictive power by integrating
it with other diagnostic data this is
going to be a
topic as we move forward here just uh
real quick to sort of
in light of these benefits our group
performed
first in transplant work using
computationalist logic analysis
the goal of this preliminary work was
actually pretty simple it was just to
reproduce
conventional ishlp grades to show that
we can to test out the tools in a new
field and
and to show their potential value to
honestly what's often a skeptical
clinical audience
um the idea being at the very least if
we could reproduce ifhlt grades we can
at least
develop something that is more reliable
than you know one pathologist compared
to another that can at least attack the
issue of
of integrator agreement um for this
effort we utilized a handcrafted feature
engineering approach you can
quickly go through these images in the
right of the screen here what we did was
basically start with simple segmentation
of
a piece of h and estology and frame a uh
into three basic parts
dark gray as myocytes light gray as
interstitial and stroma and then white
is all the non-myocyte nuclei
those are usually lymphocytes but not
only um once we had sort of basic
segmentation what we do is we use
proximity graphing features
to basically figure out which
lymphocytes are sort of clustering
closely to one another start identifying
these
closely grouped lymphocytes um and
through some thresholding of when to
lump these clusters together split them
apart
we're able to reproduce one of the key
components of ice hlp grading which is
lymphocyte foci
they're not very well defined in the
criteria but they are key to
differentiating
1r 2r and 3r so we had to be able to
reproduce it with our
feature approach and we did so and then
finally we
we identified specific compartments of
the tissue uh myocardium versus
endocardium and just to sort of better
describe where lymphocyte activity is
occurring
and when you put all this together the
end result is promising in that it's
indistinguishable from human
pathologists we were basically
non-inferior in terms of integrator
agreement and and it really looked like
uh
essentially another pathologist in the
room you couldn't tell the difference
between our algorithm
and and a dozen other pathologists um
and this proof of concept was i think
nice and it shows the power of the tools
but
it really only addresses this issue of
reliability
and does not touch on the issues of
accuracy or risk stratification which
probably results in the most
patient harm in patient issues um
we were obviously still just working
within this ishlp framework we were just
working with h
e so we really didn't have a lot of
additional details and again we didn't
focus on sort of the more actionable
clinical issues which is
diagnostic accuracy and prediction it's
in light of these limitations that we
turn to the central experiment of this
talk
um for uh added detail and clarity
if uh modern approach with computational
histologic analysis was good we figured
that an even more modern approach using
both computational analysis and
modern molecular diagnostics would be
really good
um quantitative histologic analysis
obviously does not need to be confined
to just traditional h
e samples alone early on in the process
of developing our preliminary algorithm
and rejection
we recognize that the power of these
tools could be enhanced by adding layers
of in-situ molecular detail via
immunostaining
a desire to explore these quantitative
morphomolecular
workflows if you will led us to work
with multiplex immunofluorescence and
heart transplant tissues
when it comes to explaining the lack of
agreement between
histologic grading and clinical
rejection the so-called lack of
diagnostic accuracy that we already
talked about
there are really several possible
explanations it could be just a matter
of sampling error and this is frequently
cited by people
looking at the wrong place or it could
be a matter of timing looking a little
too early or a little too late to get
the disease process you expect
i think fundamental to the research
we're going to present here is the
assertion that
even if these issues of sampling or
timing could have some
impact we assert that the tissue itself
still contains all the necessary
information within it
to assess the severity of an alloy
immune response it's just that manual h
analysis doesn't provide enough
mechanistic or immunologic details to
get us to that diagnosis
examine the the biopsies on this slide
for a second and you'll see on the left
half the two slides
on h e it can be pretty obvious when
there's a difference between the number
of little blue cells when you have a low
grade rejection and a high grade
rejection that can be
sometimes pretty obvious lots more
little blue cells in the
the right or right of the two frames
there um but when we sort of take a zoom
in look on on
discordant cases here what we see is two
two slides
same histologic grade but very different
syndromes the patient on the
the left the third piece of the tissue
in there is uh
was essentially still running three
miles a day
had a lot of little blue styles on their
biopsy but was running three miles a day
completely asymptomatic showed up to
clinic
felt like patient on the right was in
cardiogenic shock um
it's hard to appreciate the difference
in those presentations
just based on the little blue cell
counting that is done in traditional h a
histologic analysis and i think that's
where
we started getting curious about what
pieces of information are we missing
here
so the rationale for the work we're
going to perform was
pretty obvious obviously there's the
histologic side of it there's also the
fact that
since 2004 the international society of
heart and lung transplantation has
actually recognized the
problem with little blue cell counting
and is advocated for further
characterization of the nature of the
inflammatory infiltrates on biopsies
it's just that in the intervening 15
years or so
there's really been very limited
application of tissue level immune
phenotyping and heart transplant tissues
and this really stands in contrast to
other fields which uh in the last
couple of decades have had remarkable
progress based on immunological
phenotyping would improve risk
stratification identification
therapeutic targets and
so on and so forth to be honest
transplant was being left in the dust a
little bit here
beyond the sort of call to action by
bodies and success of others in other
fields
there's obviously a strong biological
rationale that performs some immune
phenotyping as well
traditionally allograft rejection is
thought of as a t-cell-mediated process
with recipients cd4 and cd8 cells
reacting against
donor alloanogens infiltrating the donor
organ and then causing a bunch of damage
this is why traditional grading focused
on roughly estimating the extent of
these little blue cells under the
assumption that
these little blue cells are all t
lymphocytes and then all the cells all
the little blue cells there are there to
cause
trouble to cause damage um with pretty
rapid advances in the field of
immunology over the past couple decades
i think this conceptual framework seems
quite outdated even within sort of the
simplified schematic on this slide which
just highlights a couple of
key players in t-cell biology it should
be clear that there's a lot more going
on than just t-cells are bad
just to highlight a few of the active
players here because we're going to hear
about them again
cd4 cells are activated by antigen
presenting cells macrophages dendritic
cells whatever it may be
and these activated cd4 cells can do a
variety of things other than just
hurt your allograft they can
differentiate into effector cd4 and cd8
cells which
can hurt your allograft they can
differentiate into or they can
cause the activation of naive cd8 cells
which can also
hurt your allograft but they can also
differentiate into regulatory t
cells especially when stimulated with
certain markers like pdl-1 the
checkpoint molecule
and these regulatory t cells in turn can
inhibit effector t cells can stimulate
pdl1 production in a variety of other
tissues both macrophages and your end
organs
and this pdl one expression in turn
beyond just helping the differentiation
of cd4 cells
when it's expressed by end organ tissue
has the ability to essentially turn off
effector t
cells um and that's why it's been such a
popular target in
immuno ecology but i i bring all of this
up just to show that there's a lot more
going on than t
cells bad and in light of even a
simplistic view of
modern immunology it seems clear that
there might be value in
better characterizing the pro and
anti-inflammatory players affecting t
lymphocytes
so that's exactly basically what we
sought to do with this experiment uh
in the context of strong biological
rationale and a clear unmet need we
embarked on this pilot work to
fully perform fully quantitative
multiplex immunofluorescence
uh in in heart transplant tissues um
we really approached two specific
hypotheses here addressing the
major clinical unmet needs we thought
were most important and
that we've already talked about um the
first
was that qmif could identify immune
phenotypes that helped resolve cases of
clinical histologic discordance uh the
so-called accuracy problem
and the second is that qmif could
identify differences in immune
phenotypes between patients at high
versus low risk of future serious
rejection
this is the so-called prediction or risk
stratification problem
our study coerced consisted of 46
transplant biopsies from the university
of pennsylvania between 2007 and 2013
the cases were selected to explore in
situ immune phenotype differences
between biopsies with
with low and high is hlt grades
zero and one rlo which two r3 are high
between biopsies with
associated with clinically silent versus
clinically evident rejection syndromes
this includes cases with clear
discordance between the histologic grade
and the clinical
syndrome and this is an area of
particular clinical relevance
and finally between biopsies from future
rejection patients versus never
rejection patients
as defined by having clinically evident
rejection within
the first three years post-transplant
the study flow diagram briefly outlines
the chord a little bit better
briefly of the the slides passing qc 22
were low grade and 11 were
high grade biopsies when we looked at
this cohort from the perspective of the
patient level rejection syndrome instead
of the grade
23 were associated with clinically
silent rejection
whereas 10 were associated with
clinically evident rejection events
should be noted that the court contained
seven examples of over
clinical histologic discordance where
either low grades were associated with
serious rejection
or high grades associated with
completely benign reject uh
clinical courses without any evidence of
rejection finally of the
19 clinically silent low-grade cases on
the far left there not the bottom
um these were uh really broken into two
potential groups
biopsies from patients who would go on
to have a serious rejection event within
the next six to
nine months and patients who would uh
never go on to develop a rejection that
was in the first three years we had 13
never rejection patients and six future
rejection patients
um
in terms of the criteria we use to
define clinically evident rejection
um we use criteria modified from a
variety of prior
efforts in heart transplantation
medicine briefly patients must be
admitted to the hospital they must
undergo rejection directed therapy
and must meet either one major or two of
the minor criteria here on this slide
which are derived from
invasive hemodynamics echocardiograms
ekgs and clinical presentation
i won't read through all the criteria
but don't give while i give a few of you
a chance to do so
i will say that these have now been used
in several nih grants they've been
sort of blessed by a variety of leaders
in transplant across the country so
they're they're
as good as criteria can be i think
um with regards to our study method the
qmif method um we deployed qmif workflow
in order to perform in situ immune
profiling on a bunch of
archived clinical ffpe tissue blocks
such as taking what was stored in our
pathology
archives and wax and and seeing what we
could get out of the custom built seven
marker panel we used for the study um
was modified from existing clio grade
panels that had been validated in
oncologic publications
and they included um pan t cell marker
cd3 which
as we've already covered is either pro
or anti-inflammatory effects depending
on the situation
uh cytotoxic t-cell marker cd8 which is
predominantly pro-inflammatory
macrophage marker cd68 which can also
have either pro or anti-inflammatory
effects depending on the environment
um regulatory t cells with fox p3
expression which are predominantly
anti-inflammatory and then checkpoint
system ligand pdl1
which is a anti-inflammatory anti-t
cell checkpoint marker
akoya biosciences led their considerable
experience with these methods to enable
the qmif workflow in this study
all the staining was performed using
their opal multiplex kits on a leica
bond rx auto standard
slide scanning was performed with a
vector polaris multi-spectral slide
scanner it's a really cool device
and uh image quantitation was before
using some informed software
um
after the introduction to computational
histology we've already done i'm going
to spare you further discussion of such
methods but
the analytical workflow here should be
relatively easy to digest
starting with raw unmixed digital slides
pixel classification is performed to
identify
pixels associated with each marker floor
form and then cell identification is
performed
via the dappy nuclear state when you
combine these workflows you are able to
essentially integrate pixel classes and
register them with cell markers enabling
single cell classification and
quantitation
um more generally and more interestingly
quite frankly for a lot of you will be
the
the why we do it and when you just sort
of look at the h
e slide at the bottom left of the screen
here
and that cellular infiltrate and it's
all it's little blue cells and it looks
like an infiltrate and maybe it's
affecting things but
when you put seven multiplex if on it
you get a lot of information out you
look at the
the ifs zoom in on that and you get the
feeling that there's a lot of biology
going on there that you're missing
with just h a and when you add a real
quantitation to it you can really start
measuring that biology and
should be pretty obvious why we were
excited to try this out
um moving on to our study results um
in total nearly 200 000 cells were
analyzed for this work
um cd3 positive cells were the most
prevalent cell type
while fox p3 cells were the least
prevalent
and then it was actually already a
fairly novel finding it appeared that
pdl1 was pretty widely expressed in
heart transplant tissue which never
actually been clearly defined or
documented
at least in human samples
moving on to the more interesting
results however when we look at the
biopsies by
is hlt grade what we see is that there
are dramatic differences in
the more pro-inflammatory markers um
there's seven times more cd8 cells in
high-grade biopsies there's four times
more cd3 cells and high-grade biopsies
and there's 2.5 times more cd68 cells in
the high-grade biopsies
um when we look at sort of the
more immune modulatory markers
the fox b3 pdl1 we see really only more
modest differences between low and high
ishlt grades
there's perhaps uh a modest difference
in fox p3 cells approaching
significance although with multiple
testing of borderline
um there's more overall pdl-1 cells but
when we look at the pdl-1h score which
is a composite metric of prevalence and
staining intensity we see that they're
really quite similar to low grade and
high grades
so what we really see when we look at
these cases by grade is we see that
high grade has a lot more
pro-inflammatory cd3 cells
and perhaps that's not that surprising
that they were the most prevalent cells
when we look at our results instead
of with our sort of great agnostic
uh point of view which is based on the
clinical rejection syndrome rather than
the ice hlc grade we see some
pretty different findings that i think
are worthy of more discussion than those
ishlt grade findings um first of all we
see that
the high grade biopsies
that the high grade biopsies and the
clinically evident biopsies share
one thing in clear common uh they both
have a lot more cd3 and taste
the high grade biopsies more cd3 cd8
clinically evident biopsies more
cd3 cd8 it's really gets more
interesting when we look at the
clinically silent
biopsies the the ones that were from
patients with no evidence of rejection
at all
when we look at these biopsies we see
first of all that silent rejection had
interestingly twice as much cd68
macrophage staining as
evident or serious rejection this is
interesting because when we looked at it
by is hlt grade
we saw that high grade rejection at all
the cd68 cells and now it's the
clinically silent cases that do so
this is somewhat discordant between
grade and and
clinical rejection syndrome and it's
going to be worthy of further discussion
in a moment
when we look at the immune modulators um
we see also that when we break our
cohort down by clinical syndrome we see
more dramatic differences in these
immune modulators
fox p3 cells the t-regs are twice as
common in
clinically silent biopsies and the
people in the checkpoint molecules
whether we look at it by h-score or by
prevalence are
much more common in clinically silent
rejection these are interesting findings
and certainly suggest that uh
there may be important biology that goes
unrecognized by traditional grading
framework we don't see much difference
between these markers and traditional
grapes but when we look at clinical
syndromes we see
some biology coming out with these
anti-inflammatory markers
um given that one of the major reasons
to perform this work was to
resolve these cases of long-standing
clinical histologic discordance where
the biopsy grade doesn't match the
patient syndrome it's really instructive
to look at our study cohort by
by uh essentially contingency table
designation in other words
grade high low and syndrome
and syndrome severe or not severe silent
or evident
when we do it this way we see some
pretty interesting findings
first of all traditional t cell markers
cd3 and cd8 do not help us resolve
discordant cases um you look here
whether the patient is clinically silent
or clinically evident with their
rejection syndrome the two bars on the
far right
they have much more cd3 and tda than
patients with low castela histologic
grades
and again whether they're sick or not
sick um this makes sense um
since cd3 and cd8 cells were the most
prevalent cell types
in this study and since traditional
grading is all about
sort of roughly estimating the number of
little blue cells it makes sense that
high-grade biopsies have lots of these
low-grade biopsies that few of these
but unfortunately it also makes this
rather unhelpful
because what it clearly is not good at
doing is telling who's sick and who's
not sick
sick low-grade biopsies look just like
sick high grade bio they're look like
just like healthy low-grade biopsies
with these markers and
stick high-grade biopsies look just like
well high-grade biopsies with these
markers
when we look at the anti-inflammatory
markers po1 fox p3 and cd68 however
we see that a pretty different story
emerges
um when we look at clinically silent
cases regardless of their grade we see
that they have much more and
similar amounts of pdl one and foxy
through the green and
uh gray bars here and again this
is interesting because these are very
different in histologic grade but very
similar in these markers
when we look at the clinically sick
patients the sort of little bars
adjacent to each of those um whether the
grade is high or low
they seem to have very similar amounts
of pdl1 and fox p3 and that's
interesting because it really correlates
with their rejection syndrome not their
gray
um one in other interesting finding here
is the cd68
uh markers which are really only
markedly elevated in the clinically
silent
high-grade discordant cases if you
recall in the previous slide we saw that
cd68
was much higher in high grade and then
interestingly much higher in clinically
silent rejection
than we broke it down by clinical
syndrome it seems pretty clear that the
clinically silent
uh high-grade rejection events are
driving this phenomenon
um bringing apparently five times as
many macrophages
to the cohorts uh as any other group um
i think for those who who like to
to see something to believe it i think
it's pretty instructive to actually look
at the
raw slides here as well first of all
and just sort of from a higher zoom out
perspective
you look at the h and e bright field
slides on the left and the low grade
slides look pretty similar not a lot of
little blue cells
the high grade slides look pretty
similar much more
cellular infiltration but when we start
looking at the
the qmis data here the raw data what we
see is that
the high grade clinically silent biopsy
at the top right
looks very different from the high grade
clinically serious rejection syndrome at
the bottom right we see a lot of
sort of greens and yellows and reds and
we'll talk about what these markers are
in a second in the cellular infiltrate
of the high-grade clinically silent case
whereas it's much less interesting than
all things considered in the clinically
uh serious rejection high grade case
when we look at the
the low-grade biopsies um we see that
really bland immune almost the lack of
immunostaining in the
low-grade clinically serious rejection
event at the the bottom sort of third
column
bottom row um whereas when we look at
the low-grade clinically styling biopsy
we see a diffuse green staining that
really makes it look sort of like the
at least the background pattern we see
in the high grade clinically silent case
we'll get to this in just a second here
now
to shed a little more light on what's
going on
um when we look at uh the unmixed slides
now broken down by single marker
channels we start
getting into the really more interesting
findings first of all the clinically
silent biopsies are represented by the
first and third row
um so at the top we have the the top row
we have clinically silent low grade
the second row is clinically evident low
grade the third row is clinically silent
high grade and the fourth row is
clinically evident high grade
um when we look at the the slides
corresponding to
clinically silent rejection uh the cd68
pdl1
and fox p3 channels here in red boxes we
see that uh
these clinically styling cases have a
lot more cd68 a lot more pdl one and a
lot more fox p3 relative to the clinic
with serious rejections
um when we look at the the second row
here in the green boxes
this is the low grade clinically evident
rejection case the so-called false
negative
uh we see an almost complete absence of
macrophage pdl1 and
t-reg signaling in this in this piece of
tissue and it's pretty compelling for
the loss of anti-inflammatory markers
here
and then finally when you when you when
you look at the the fourth
row which is the high grade clinically
evident case um while in the
the sort of third column you see it's
got plenty of cd8 cells
but you don't see as much of compared at
least to the third row which is
high grade the clinically silent you see
much less pdl one much less
box p2 t-reg and relatively fewer
macrophages as well
so again what we're seeing here is that
when we
look at these immune modulators what
ultimately comes out of the equation is
that
anti-inflammatory markers while not
making up the bulk of cells present
um seem to have a significant
correlation with the clinical syndrome
of the
patient who the biopsy was obtained from
moving on to for a moment now to
onto rejection prediction instead of
just rejection diagnosis
um if you recall um a subset of the
study co-work
of the low-grade clinically silent
biopsies in the study court were
taken from patients who either would or
would not go on to develop a future
rejection event
in the table on the top right the
biopsies of never rejection patients
have markedly higher levels of pdl-1 and
fox p3 compared to the future rejection
patients
um and what actually gets even more
interesting is when you look at the
graph below that when we break our
future rejection
patients up by the proximity of the
biopsy to the actual rejection event
what we see is that greater than six
months prior to rejection they have
modestly reduced pdl1 and fox p3 levels
compared to the never rejection patients
that's the
second group of columns in that graph
but when we go
closer to the time of rejection three to
six weeks prior to rejection the far
right bars we see an almost complete
disappearance of fox p3 and pdl1
signaling in these tissues
this suggests that these markers are not
just somewhat predictive
of of of outcomes and severity of
rejection syndrome but that they're also
dynamic in the tissues in our
are biologically active over time um
to summarize this work i think
i think we've discovered a number of
sort of interesting things in this pilot
research that are that are worthy of
further consideration in further
investigation to summarize the finding
generally quantitative in situ immune
phenotypic
biopsies is clearly feasible and i think
also clearly adds some value to a
rejection diagnosis
although we haven't fully characterized
just how much value
in terms of diagnostic potential pdo1
expressing cells regulatory t-cells and
macrophages
may help us discriminate between
patients with serious versus silent
rejection trajectories
in terms of risk stratification pdl1 and
fox p3 levels are dynamic and may help
us
risk stratify patients at increased
short and long term
risk of serious rejection events and
finally on a mechanistic level it
appears that
pdi1 and fox p3 seem to impart some
degree of alloprotective effect
on the tissues they inhabit uh
findings that are certainly worthy of
further study and possibly and
hopefully uh worthy of therapeutic
targeting someday
um like all work this work has
limitations um
like most pilot work it has quite a few
of them um the limitations here are
obviously a small number of total
patients in biopsy samples this was
pilot work
um but positive pilot working compelling
pilot work
um the anti-body panel was somewhat
limited so
obviously you know a seven marker
multiplex panel is better than h
e but it certainly isn't exhaustive in
terms of all the potential
markers of interest for immunologic
processes going on in allografts
um and we also had a bit of a lack of
co-expression phenotyping at least in
this deployment of qmif
um which is to say we didn't really try
and figure out exactly what cells are
these that are expressing pdl pdl-1
for example are these macrophages are
these
t-regs are these myocytes this
information is going to be important and
we currently don't have it but
we will someday um it's certainly a
future direction for us is that type of
co-expression phenotyping
in terms of future directions obviously
we want to expand the sample size we
want to do co-phenotyping
um we also want to expand the image
analysis methods used if you recall from
our sort of preliminary work on the h
e's we talked a lot about spatial
relationships infiltration patterns
density metrics
um where the sites were occurring uh we
didn't really perform that
degree of overall image analysis and
feature mapping
in this work but we can um and we will
because i expect if raw single cell
quantitation is valuable
spatially spatially understanding that
quantitation is going to be even
more valuable and then finally pathomix
approaches deeper characterizations of
these cell subtypes uh through either
rna-seq or dna or or barcoding or a
variety of other sort of
higher plex applications to to learn a
bit more about some of the players in
this tissue would all be i think of
significant interest
conclusions and acknowledgments we've
covered a lot of ground here and i hope
that
you found most of it comprehensible and
interesting
in terms of take-home points i on a
general level i think this talk really
focused on improving post-transplant
care it also
talked about utilizing modern tools to
maximally extract information from
underutilized resources and that's a lot
of of what
sort of drew me to these methodologies
yes i'm a transplant doctor and
interested in that but i'm
also interested in finding ways to make
the most out of
the data and the resources already
obtained and already available to us
um histologic analysis is
perhaps getting forgotten about in 21st
century medicine a little bit it's
it's not some relic of a bygone era in
medicine in my opinion
there's a wealth of information
contained within these histologic
samples and
and modern software approaches can
really help us maximally get at that
information
and then to share it and ultimately to
integrate it with the rest of the 21st
century diagnostic toolkit
heart transplantation medicine is a
tissue-rich field with
major unmet needs and tissue analysis
and it really makes it ideally suited
for demonstrating the translational
potential of some of these methods
i hope that the research covered in this
presentation has helped to highlight
some of this potential and i thank you
for your attention
a few acknowledgements real quick uh my
close research
collaborators ken marley's and mike
feldman the team at uh coyote
biosciences bethany cliff
and the rest of them for all their help
with this project and uh my programming
team and aunt andrew and sarah
questions
thank you so much dr pacer for this very
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's go ahead and get started we
certainly got quite a number of
questions
so dr pacer first up
what would account for fox p3 decrease
in the three to six weeks prior to
transplant
would you account that to stress or
stress on the heart
a good question um i don't have a good
answer for it
it's certainly one of the questions
raised by i think these results um
and one of those things that demand a
further look given that we've sort of
found it in
relatively small and pilot data um
that's the question is the lack of fox
p3 driven by
the start of an alloy immune process
going the wrong way differentiating
towards a pro-inflammatory method
is it you know is it under
immunosuppression resulting in this is
it over immunosuppression actually
suppressing fox p3 differentiation
it's hard to say um more biological
characterization is required but i think
that's that's sort of one of those
important actionable questions that
data like this raise
wonderful up next another question uh
with pdl1 inhibitors in wide usage
and your results showing a strong link
between pdl1 activity and heart damage
is there a concern that these
medications should be dangerous to heart
transplant patients
um so there's definitely case
literature on this question
in transplant patients there's case
reports and multiple of them of
transplant patients receiving checkpoint
inhibitors for
malignancies they develop
post-transplant and there are quite a
few case reports of these patients
developing us
through acute rejection syndrome shortly
after starting treatment
there's also plenty of case literature
on in
non-transplant patients introduced to
checkpoint molecules these patients
sometimes develop uh
rarely but not that infrequently
autoimmune myocarditis
so certainly it sounds like the the
checkpoint system is active in both
native and transplant myocardium and and
thus checkpoint inhibitors are should be
used with i would say
great caution in the post-transplant
setting although obviously we don't have
the strongest data to recommend this it
would be based on case series and these
and this type of data i think
it's reasonable to be very cautious
absolutely up next
uh it says that this presentation is
dealing in particular with
cellular rejection what is your opinion
on the interest
of multiplex labeling for the knowledge
of
antibody mediated rejection and help for
diagnosis at
biopsy uh great question um from uh
from patrice brunebo and france who i
know also works with this platform at
heart and i think we're
part of a small group using it um it's
an important question so in this
particular study i can
i can say that none of the cases in the
entire cohort
met current criteria for antibody
mediator rejection either on h
e or on if um so i do think we had a
predominantly cellular mediated
rejection population or at least as much
as you can ever say that with the
current definitions
um i think that it's highly useful for
investigating amr as well as uh cellular
rejection i just haven't done
the amr work yet it's uh it's in
planning it's like we
it's it's part of an upcoming grant uh
which which recently got in front we're
going to investigate
both cellular rmn and humor alarm
because it's
clearly this was helpful or at least
interesting and compelling in cellular
rejection and i think the next step is
look it in about immediate
rejection and expand numbers and and
really just try and
understand as much as you can about the
the alloy immune environment and then
that's going to require investigating
both arms of the immune system which are
probably both active
in most cases of projection to some
degree
absolutely so i think this is an
overarching question
how do you envision results like these
changing the medical care of
heart transplant patients
i think results like these are
unfortunately not too that looked enough
to change it yet
but they certainly get you
tempted to think about how you might be
able to deploy more
personalized strategies in
post-transplant care um
if you can identify a high-risk group of
patients versus a low-risk group of
patients
in that high-risk group you may be able
to surveil them more frequently you may
not wean their prednisone
ever or at least not as quickly um you
may target higher attack reliance levels
and
on the other end of the spectrum in the
very low risk population
you'd be able to wean their
immunosuppression more quickly and
limit their exposures to infectious risk
and malignancy and
so i think it's really about uh the
right therapy for the right patient and
tools like this seem to get us closer to
identifying who is the right and wrong
patient for our kind of different
approaches um
deployment in a in a prospective trial
will be needed i think to
figure out exactly how to do this but um
but first you have to develop the
diagnostic tools that let you think it's
possible and this is i think a start of
that
fantastic um so another question that we
have
is um a kidney transplant biopsy
multiplex study using a coia technology
platform
reported variable cell type
infiltrations
so macrophage dominant versus t cell
dominant
and once again this is in renal
transplant
samples did you see any patient to
patient variation of immune cell type
and heart transplant biopsies
uh absolutely so i that that recent
paper um came out right around the same
time as this paper came out um
[Music]
so we all you know there's like i said a
small group of us in transplant space
who have sort of been thinking about
this and and it's uh
yes first of all we do see variation
patient patient actually a fair amount
of variation in patient
patient and that's uh important to take
in the context of this work
with our small end and a lot of
variation patient patient um well
you need more m to really know what
you're dealing with that said
um there's definitely you know yes
there's there's patients who had a more
macrophage predominant pattern and a
more
t cell dominant pattern in this study
because we decided to
sort of jettison conventional grading
and also introduce
um a conceptual framework for looking at
rejection which is more based on uh
hard clinical endpoints uh overt
allograft injury um i think we were able
to see that yes there's two different
sort of dominant patterns of infiltrate
one's with more macrophages once with
less but what we also found was that the
one with more macrophages seems to be
doing
better um they seem to have they seem to
represent that sort of discordant high
grade
subset um and i think that's something
that the the kidney work did not
look at so i can't say whether this
process is also true in their organ
um but in our organ because we chose to
look at sort of rejection both
histologically and by
clinical syndrome we were able to sort
of tease out that not only do the
infiltrates look different but that
maybe their fates also are quite
different and maybe the macrophages are
either a
late response to an initial injury which
sort of
interrupts a damaging process or maybe
it's just because the initial
inflammatory response is more macrophage
dense that it's less
aggressive um a little hard to say with
just sort of the
the data we have so far but i i think
that uh
parsing out what these different
infiltration patterns mean on a patient
level is
what our work supported strongly
supports doing going forward and i think
hopefully when the kidney audience sees
what we've done they'll think about how
to
how to look at it in a similar framework
to start teasing that out
excellent so we have a ton of great
questions
um we're going to roll into another one
how confident can you be that regional
inconsistencies
of endomyocardial biopsies do not
account for some
of the quite intriguing cellular
infiltration versus clinical
presentation
especially in view of the dynamics you
suggested during the course
of cardiac allograf rejection
sure a key question with basically all
tissue sampling biopsy studies is how
much is sampling error and template
biasing your results um
it's a good question um i can say you
know
it's one of so first of all it's one of
the reasons why
i think whole slide imaging and spatial
features in addition to just raw cell
quantification is going to be important
um when i sort it when you when you i'll
drift back here for those who are still
on the screen when you look at
at the the patterns of infiltration
um within the sort of different cell
types what you see is
in particular with the clinically silent
cases uh the pdl-1 signature yes it's
focally targeted at the site of
infiltrate but it seems to also be
somewhat diffusely spread throughout the
tissue in the clinically silent cases
um i'm hopeful although certainly can't
prove yet that that's
that this suggests that there are
diffuse processes less susceptible to
sampling error
processes like broad general pl1
expression within the interstitium
um that may help you identify a
high-risk group versus a low-risk group
so i think
while yes infiltrates are spotty and
patchy perhaps the pdl1 expression is
not
and and that's something which is going
to be robust to sampling error
not confirmed but suspicious when you
sort of look at the actual raw images
here i mean that's
something that i'm quite interested in
definitely more research to be had um
so let's go on to another question
um we will only really have time for
maybe two more questions
so don't be alarmed if we don't get to
your question this time
we will address it in a follow-up email
to you
the individuals who asked the questions
um so up next
is seven marker multiplex
immunofluorescence is clearly a powerful
tool in the context of your explorations
but the immune system is quite complex
have you given thought as to
how you might probe the general immune
cell type you identify like
cd68 and cd4 in more detail to better
tease out mechanisms and targets
sure i've given a thought it's an
important question
because h e gives you no biological
resolution
uh to speak of in terms of the cell
types certainly seven marker if gives
you a lot more information but certainly
it doesn't give you every piece of
information um
there are some types of fox p3 cells
there are some types of cd4 cd83 cells
that
are not fully characterized with work
like this there are some types of
macrophages
all of these have potential implications
and i think once you start honing in on
on broad patterns
which are well correlated with
interesting clinical syndromes that's
when you then want to dive deeper into
into specific subsets of your tissue
and do more more detailed deeper
biological
investigations of marker types and so i
think
there are quite a few dna barcoding
technologies out there which allow
semi spatial high plex 40 50 100 plex
quantification of proteins in rna and i
think that's sort of
once you once you have identified
actionable patients and actionable
tissue samples
that's where you that's sort of the next
step is to dive deeper into it
in that way and really get much
information about the immune biology as
you can to start figuring out
hard mechanisms and targetable
targetable mechanisms
all right we are just going to have one
last question
and this one seems to be more of a
method question
how long did it take to run these
markers and
were they run on the same tissue section
or separate tissue sections
right in terms of of time uh my
understanding is that um
basically you can run 30 slides
overnight so you can do most of what we
did for this cohort in a day
um between the the auto stainer and then
and then and scanning with
the vector polaris which is a fast
process which won't take long at all
um in terms of whether they were
processed on
uh basically what we did for this work
was we we took
uh residual ffp blocks out of our
pathology archives
and just cut a fresh fresh glass slide
for each biopsy so
each patient biopsy event got one glass
slide
with however many pieces of tissue that
had
wax for that case and one glass slide
for patient
sent uh and and then stained and scanned
so
that's pretty much how the we did not do
multiple sections for biopsy
although you certainly could it didn't
seem to be particularly necessary for
this work to get
and a pretty good preliminary data
all right um well that is it for the
questions so
so thank you again dr pacer um do you
happen to have any final comments
for the audience um i think we've
covered uh
a lot of data in the talk and then a lot
of good questions afterwards
so i just want to thank you all for
attending
fantastic and i too would also like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for all of your fantastic questions
um any questions that we did not have
time to address
during this webinar will be addressed by
the speaker
using the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
we would once again like to thank dr
pacer for giving us his time today to
discuss his exciting research
we would also like to thank labrutz and
nikoia for underwriting today's
educational webcast as previously
mentioned
this webcast will be viewable on demand
following its conclusion
you will get an email from lab roots
alerting you when it's available for
replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
additionally at the end of this webinar
you will be asked to complete a brief
survey
after which you'll be redirected to the
akoya academy webpage
where you can find previously recorded
webinars highlighting tips
tricks and best practices to get the
most out of our technology
this concludes the live webinar hope you
all enjoy the rest of your day